Her low freak bitches.
I'm supposed to ask you about it.
Johnny Gill who thought he could
beat Oscar de la Hoya. Oh yeah, man.
You know why somebody told me?
Somebody told me.
How did you know about that one man?
I think it was Thompson.
Gloria told me that that was,
that was one of the days when that's
back when asked. It was still, you know,
fighting too.
That's what made me really angry.
They asked who was whipping somebodies
ass and I'm sitting next to a balladeer,
you know, I respect you.
You get singing on it,
but don't point to know Friday and go,
I could whip him that.
I don't want to hit that man.
He really said that vehemently
man jumped up and I even,
I even the fact that you brought it up,
it ain't like I'm snitching.
I told him, pharisees,
you ask him the same room,
making sure that ask it
knows that you feel that way.
I want to be there.
I'm making sure he knows that you uh,
balladeer crooner you could
whip them out. Yeah, man,
that was up to me.
That was the highest insert and of the
highest level man you make your money,
he roses flattening and all that saying
you're going to look at a frightening
and talking about how could whip him.
Come on man. He needs to know that.
He needs to know you feel that way.
I did it with Mike Tyson and rough house
used to talk shit. Oh yeah. My, my,
my I do this and that.
The MAG Bababa about so one day we will
all together and I said you know Mike,
this dude told me whip your ass man.
He really,
he tells me all the time,
why don't you tell Mike
what you be telling me?
Why lashed them turning the Koolaid
Ms Chair, what did he said Mike?
He didn't say nothing. She didn't
say nothing. That was my whole point.
I mean you probably encounter before.
I've been in the hood up in the barbershop
sometime and I got to tell folks my
name, he's like Yo man, cause man
don't make nothing man. What do you do?
You work for ups, right? Don't
bring up Max names. Then staff it.
Bring up another truck drivers,
cause I'll take me out to Gleason's
rate now and pick out any heavyweight,
somebody who you never seen on TV and
he'll make you call them integrators.
Stop it man. You got to
fight it. You don't do what?
This guy does respect what he does and
I said him jumping around and we'll have
your truck. I'm trying to beat you on
your routers. It's not going to happen.
When it happened, man,
Dude's get delusional about
their ability to kick ass.
He really thought he back in the day,
I don't have been. Maybe he's more.
You just think that he felt,
he felt he was more powerful,
faster, but you never, you never
boxed before as an the jewelry.
I'm talking about being a
man. I was like, what are you
talking about being a man?
That's a dude that doesn't understand
what an eight week campus or like an eight
week trial he was.
He was bumped him.
I think he was working out with bags and
he had a little cut on and everything.
I was like, you know those muscles
don't translate to a wind. Brenna.
People translate to best in show
at the bodybuilding cancer context.
Not that you're going to win the fight.
And if you look at real fighters,
they don't have the chisel body like
Gi Joe. You know what I'm saying?
Look at the Anderson Silva.
Look at his body looked normal man.
And look what happens when
those dudes come in with the,
you know the Gi Joe King Classic.
The problem with all that muscle
is it needs fuel. You gotta,
you gotta feed them so you
only good for about 30 seconds,
20 seconds of full fury. When
you're all big like time, the guy,
he can hang on deal. It's
like riding a bull, you know,
but the boat was like real bad endurance.
Then you burn it.
Just ride them to the beware
of themselves, their arms.
They fill up with blood,
then they can't move. They get
heavy. It's crazy. You Watch,
like there's a guy named Marius,
put your Nowicki strong world's strongest
man does those crazy fucking things
where the, you know, they throw the beer
bottles in the air and the cars and shit.
You know that strong man shit.
He's one of the bunch of times and he
just started doing MMA and he gets fucked
up by fatty foods. Kay. He's throwing
some with punches and kicks off.
Tim Silvia beat the fuck out of that boy.
He had that dude purple purple as fuck.
He telling Sylvia was like,
how dare you,
I was a fucking two time heavyweight
champion or more a maybe, I don't know.
Either way.
It's a fucking world UFC heavyweight
champion and you think that you,
you can pick up a car
so you can kick his ass.
It was like a slow methodical
ass kicking by an overweight guy.
Essentially. We've got what the car's
not moving the cars and that, you know,
doing techniques. But if they can
get you in those first 15 seconds,
you could have a real big fucking problem.
Cause for those gaskets,
those guys get street people
are like, you know, yeah man.
That guy who could throw a car goes to
the supermarket and you get an argument.
He could probably throw you across the
meat section. Yeah, get back or something.
You are going to be on expecting me across
the meat section but you ain't an MMA
fighter. You know you aint
inboxed you ain't whatever. Any,
any kind of professional athlete,
whatever professionally is in respected.
Don't disrespect.
Not even thinking straight up.
Now you got me thinking about fights
and supermarkets. Yeah Dude. Yeah man.
There's no weight classes in supermarkets,
Norway.
A few years ago this dude
was talking about jumping on.
It was one of them rented
bags and asked him, yeah,
we're the same size physically.
I was like,
you really think you can beat that guy
and say we're the same size. I said, yeah,
but I've seen him run over five guys
his size. I never seen you ran over
getting a hard time going up the
steps and you mess with this boy.
You know what I'm saying? You're the same
size, but you don't want the same thing,
man. Yeah. People don't understand a super
athlete understanding until that's why.
That's why we have the ability
to buck eyes express that,
to express that. When you
get surprised. Oh Shit,
I didn't mean it wasn't
practicing. Exactly. Yeah.
You can't hang out with dudes and talk
shit. Talk Shit about how they'd fight.
Mike Tyson guys are useless.
But now I'm telling you,
if you come around me and
talking about who you whip it,
cause a lot of my friends a phrase
and I've seen him in the room,
I'm going to send him know how you feel.
Okay.